I wish I was your comment why can't
women marry someone iike what a metal
mine better care to brothers and sisters
and dear friends before we go to the
experiment and find the reactions of
these people the question that we're
going to ask today is the following
we're dealing with a misconception of
polygamy yeah we're gonna go out there
and ask males and females if your
husband or your wife was totally okay
with it you had the money you had the
time everything was okay would you want
a second husband a second wife or a
second girlfriend or a second boyfriend
that's what we're gonna find out in
shala is well also we're gonna be
talking about polygamy the pros and the
cons and also also I will be talking
about in my marriage documentary which
you'll find out very soon about this
because I was personally when I was
getting to know a sister for marriage
being told him actually a few times that
do you want to get married again and I
said well you're gonna find out what I
answered in the marriage documentary and
also can you stipulate in the contract
oh this will be answered in my matters
documentary but that's something else
let's go to Birmingham we were carried
out the experiment and come right back
and inshallah learn some beautiful
lessons about polygamy all praises
belong to allah subhanho wa taala
we'll be right back
so just
don't be scared here have you guys what
your friends yeah okay imagine yeah your
girlfriend is told to the okay with it
yes she's totally fine with it yeah okay
you got the money you've got the time to
do everything yeah she's she's okay with
yet would you would you would you want a
second girlfriend if she what's shakin
Mikey she's okay with the fam
okay she's saying to you know people get
married again you can do worry like get
another girlfriend she's saying this
calm would you want a second girl 401
Ichi if you okay good I'll put in the
corner okay okay yes you see yes yes I
can ever imagine
your husband's talk to you okay with it
yeah would you want a second husband
this is a reason why you want a second
boy okay just answer no
why not I don't have time so okay wait
we have time I'd love one another second
one you need to present why not
I just love ya I feel like you can only
like you can't have two husbands another
one
kind of an equally a minor okay okay if
you don't have one second one yes yes
yes or no what yeah okay yes yeah okay
how many two three four and three two
xenovia
okay how many two three four
and how many extra two three look you
got the money at the time
your wife is okay what yeah so do one a
second girlfriend would you want okay
all right what what like males give kind
of a different answer but as females why
why can't me have more than one husband
like we're not talking about it's not
obvious we know some permissible but
once you're in general is why can't a
female be married to two husbands is
then you to not look at somebody else
while you're in love okay so it's a more
emotional if you're more emotionally
attached to one do you agree yeah Thank
You Mel Elizabeth would you ever want a
second husband
you wouldn't I spin you know it's
actually quite interesting that okay
guys now that was quite interesting as
you saw for yourself the different
reactions etc right now we're going to
find out the results yeah okay we're
gonna cut to the chase we're gonna find
the results out I carry this experiment
out on both Instagram and also in person
in Birmingham so what we're gonna do now
is we're gonna go to the survey and
genre and we're gonna see so when we
asked males we're going to find out now
what the results were
yeah okay so are you guys ready so we
asked about 26 males if I'm not mistaken
here shockingly this is actually very
very shocking to me yeah Annie because
and I'm a man is well no no I love
Brahmas around in me as well 35 percent
of them said yes 65 percent said nope so
I came to the conclusion that there are
no men left in Birmingham suddenly but
besides that the ones who said yes 67
percent said they would want one extra
co-wife or call girlfriend 11 percent
said free they would want three partners
11 percent said for and another 11
percent said they want four plus so
there was some really brothers out there
so what we did is we said okay that kind
of you know give and take because some
of the questions the promised they
didn't really understand the way of
saying even though I said if you had no
money I mean if you had the money if
you're at the time and your wife or
girlfriends talk to you okay with it
would you want to go and do this but
after we asked them some of them said I
might not have the time so they didn't
need to understand my question so I
would give it a ratio of 60 to 40
percent yeah after speaking to them now
going to sister so we asked we asked the
females okay we asked me was a very same
question your husband is totally okay
with it would you want today's second
part in a second husband or a second
boyfriend yeah we lost 25 of them and
here was a result it's quite expected
really 88 percent said no 12 percent
said yes right now even that 12 said
that said yes there was some
giggling and I think they saw it as a
job but let's go with it no problem yeah
well say 90 percent said no Tim person
said yes okay now there's a little twist
to this whole experiment I said to
myself hold on a second this is this is
quite interesting because why would
cause majority of the men obviously
there's some men who are happy with
their wife or just beg your friend what
if it may be generally but the results
that I got were a bit shocking I was
very honest with them yeah as you can
see I didn't play around I'm very honest
with it inshallah so I said let's add a
little twist to this yes so we said okay
we're gonna go back to the meals
what can I ask them that a very similar
question in a little bit of different
way and with what what would the results
be so this was quite interesting we
asked them so we do this off camera what
a variety of people called some people
and we asked him the question we said
look there is a lady or a woman who
comes and says look all I want is the
sexual pleasure that's it I don't want
nothing else from you no strings
attached yeah we made this very very
clear and we asked about 20 males yeah
and we said to them look no strings
attached would if this was the case and
this lady or this girl whoever she is
she just said look this is what I want
from you I'm a very busy woman I'm you
know I miss independent you know I don't
need a man in my life that's all I need
him for
would you do it now this was very
shocking look at the results 95% of
those men said yes five percent said no
so now the question that we all need to
ask ourselves is this why is it that
when we set a second wife a second
girlfriend even some whozit men even
though they're loud yeah we know a lot
of religions Mormonism Hinduism Sikhism
Christianity Judaism they allow his
wealth why is it that 60 percent said no
but when it came to no strings attached
there was a paradigm shift and they were
saying yes yes that kind of yes well I
want to take you guys to a little
experiment I've also done a new research
that was done yet and I want to read
this out for you guys a shock because
this kind of brings me back to this
point yeah science has yet definitely to
pronounce on whether humans are
naturally monogamous or polygamous the
human male body provides ambiguous clues
to the answer but the balance of the
balance of the evidence indicates that
we are biologically inclined towards
monogamy
now here this idea while retaining an
urge to sleep around now that's quite
interesting so there is this urge yeah
to sleep around now connecting that with
the twist that we had that we've done
that kind of tells me that made men they
prefer to have a partner a mistress a
citrate side chick or an Yannick
girlfriend with no strings attached
so it still shows me that men have that
high sex drive that they're all they
want another partner with no commitments
now I want before I come to the issue of
polygamy and its pros and cons I just
want to prove to you guys that this
study there was another study that was
taken that was done ok so this was the
biggest experiment that was done with
200,000 participants across
cross-cultural with 53 Nations
53 nations and they came to the
conclusion that men have a higher sex
drive than woman and a man thinks about
sex more often than a woman now just
just to further prove my point that for
example men spend billions of pounds on
nog Rafi males magazines where there's
half naked naked woman yes
women's legs but you will never see a
woman spending that much of money be it
on you know oh I want to go and buy a
magazine that shows me man's hairy legs
and I get turned on it doesn't happen
strip clubs a majority of the strip
clubs disproportionately are a female
strip crops yeah they're there for males
and I can object to their code and
gentlemen's club yet but when it comes
to females for females that do go to
these men strip clubs majority of them
is fairly strong that they go there
because
usually the fingers you know they have
that you know girls night out whoever
that may be and also like I said to you
before billions of pounds is being spent
on these things and not only their
advertisements what does a chocolate bar
a water gross lighting whatever you may
call it a car what on earth has that got
to do with the female that they always
have to put a female dressed up in a
certain way why because a man is born in
that way is visual yeah you guess you
know sexually stimulated visually but
with a female that's not the case what
that does is that proves me further that
a man has a higher sex drive and not
only that but also he is naturally
polygamist now you thought you you can
see you know II when I taking a word for
it however I should make something clear
I am not endorsing that you can inter
polygamy or not I'm just trying to show
you the [ __ ] am i it my aim here is in
the White House to debunk claims
misconceptions about Islam and to prove
that this Quran is from Allah because
it's reality now let's go to non-muslims
here there are two books to us support
this claim backed by scientific studies
and analysis sex at dawn that's what's
called the prehistoric origins of modern
sexuality by christopher ryan and
cecilia jetha and the myth of monogamy
monogamy by david p bearish and Judith
Eve Lipton both of these books are
available online and in and in
bookstores so non-muslims even testify
to this reality recent study shows that
British men are much more likely than
British woman to believe that humans are
naturally polygamists according to new
research despite the majority of the
country's population
believing that polygamy is morally wrong
almost half of men 46 percent think that
it is not natural to have only one
sexual partner now moving swiftly on
guys
know there's a phrase I've come across
yet a lick me has been polygamy polygamy
has been practiced in history with all
kinds of nations
yeah it has been practiced all the time
men can reproduce in their 60s and 70s
in the 80s
woman generally get into the menopause
around their 50s yes that's another
evidence why nation forgive me and also
we know a lot of men die more often
women live a bit longer also a majority
of the
prison occupants ah maybe I go so we
know that back in those days they didn't
have DNA so if a woman had four husbands
and had sex with one of them you don't
know who the baby is
but if a man had four wives you know who
the fathers you know who the mark the
mothers there's a lot of jicama behind
it yeah okay
so sisters let's just hold on yeah
before you guys go crazy I'm gonna drive
this point home it's gonna be beneficial
for all of us yeah there is a phrase
called serial monogamist now I've heard
of serial murderers and serial killers
but a serial monogamist
and it says Donald Trump Larry King who
have not the Playboy that I have on that
paper thing Charlie Sheen live openly
with multiple girlfriends now they are
called serial monogamist why because
they are not is illegal to get married
again so they are serial monogamist a
gay married divorced married divorced
married divorced their wife becomes like
that's what Donald Trump and Larry King
did when their wife became older they
replaced the old wife to a new wife and
what happens is coming at the cost of
destroying one relationship totally
abundant in abandoning and going moving
onto another one this is a hump and this
happens in our society why cause a man
wants to get married again but because
it's illegal what he does is he says
okay I have to divorce you ruin and
destroy a marriage yes you really
destroy a marriage now I know sometimes
polygamy is not done in the right way it
can also destroy marriages also we're
gonna come to that later but these
athletes these rock stars they sleep
around with hundreds and thousands of
women why so Allah has sent this
legislation for it to be done in an
ethical way not in an unethical way
where you go and abuse it and sleep
around with girls mistresses side chicks
and girlfriends and abuse them and give
them no rights it actually puts them in
a vulnerable position because you're
using and abusing them Allah says no if
you're gonna do it you do it in the
right way
marry a surah nisa verse free Mary in
twos threes and fours but if you cannot
be just marry only one and the prophet
sallallaahu has seldom told us that on
the day of judgment a man will come
leaning on one side why is he need one
on one side because he was unjust to one
of the wives so this is not a joke this
is a serious matter and we just
but the whole point of this video is
once again not to promote polygamy yeah
I need I believe it's a solution but I'm
not here to do that do it or not do it
I'm trying to show you why the Quran is
from Allah and this misconception that's
I'm trying to answer yeah this is a man
this is a man who has come to the
morning show yeah this comes in the
morning show we have the perfect
polygamous relationship he's got two
girlfriends now this is hypocrisy yeah
not these people yeah you are allowed to
have two girlfriends it's fine you can
have two girlfriend it's called come to
the morning show it's look me and my two
girlfriends but can you get married
again or no married new can I get
married again no sorry you cannot get
married again and three both the woman
equally and give them rise and honor
them and speak to the Father no no no
you cannot do that but two girlfriends
is fine you know what's more pathetic
than this well this lady says that I
sleep with men to save their marriages
she's a prostitute she sells herself she
sleeps around with men and she actually
I watch the video she says that these
men go home happy she goes because then
since life is dead their wives don't
want to have sex with him anymore so
he's saying she's saying I'll come and
see if their marriages so in another
ways is polygamy done in a unethical way
you're using refusing a woman
emotionally in all kinds of ways and
this is allowed okay
cheating is not a crime the edges of a
crime being a prostitute to serve other
men married men is not a crime having
two girlfriends it's fine side chicks
girlfriends mistresses beautiful yeah
and lot of these rich people that they
have here but if you want to get married
again in the right way and treat them
both equally
sorry that's that's not allowed this is
the pinnacle of hypocrisy and that's why
we have the wire files brought to you by
survivor studios to debunk this very
claim polygamy obviously it's finished
it's what allah subhanho wa taala and
you have a lot of brothers that get
gassed and hide they don't even do in
the [ __ ] rough even even waking up for
fudger but you're too busy concentrated
on fulfilling the Sunnah yeah because
you love them online is messenger so
much you know I have to feel this or not
brother go do your first first before
you talk about this and a lot of the
time not a real time sometimes men abuse
this how they get married divorced
married divorced married
most murders they marry sisters with
intentions of divorcing yeah it's being
abused this has happened yes not Muslims
that's why we say brothers and sisters
it's very important that our brothers
fear allah subhanho wa taala and also
our sisters because i hear a lot of
horror stories where a brother comes
yanny maybe not in this country in
another country where it's legal it's
allowed comes and says look I want to
get married again
yeah and the sister disappeared with the
kids boycotted him ruined his life
because these kids why basically tell
him get lost and go to hell literally
not metaphorically literally go to hell
we had a meaning look instead of you
heard my feelings I rather you going o
disobey unless legislation go yeah and
the co commissioner yeah sisters have to
feel the subhanho wa taala is what we
have to be balanced here this is a
reality if we go with the premise if we
agree that different things should be
treated in different ways catered
different ways the evidence and the
science and the Quran and the Sunnah
firstly science comes after proved to us
that men are treated in a different way
now we can either either accept this
reality or reject it and live in a lie
and this is one of the reasons why I've
done this video to show why polygamy
Alice one service legislated it when
it's done the right way
otherwise it's done in an unethical way
where non-muslims practiced this they
have girlfriends multiple sleeping
around back his happy days abusing woman
no rights they have no rights but when
this have done the right way for when
you're married again you're going under
that woman might be a sister I want to I
want to get married again this is why I
can offer bang bang bang speak to the
father give her a woody ma give her her
mother in a right way
well my this is something that is from
the religion and any man I admire the
man I admire no one else is very clearly
yeah and I discussed this in my marriage
documentary you saw I discuss in my
marriage documentary because I was
setting these conditions off for example
I want to get to assist get to know
sister for marriage but she said that
you're not out to the America she wants
to play it in the contract
yeah now me I'm gonna say I want to get
married again the issue is no stiffly in
the contract is this an out is this not
allowed all this we'll talk about in the
matter of you mention genre this is a
very important question
what just to drive the point home that
this polygamous relation is a solution
to mankind so in a nutshell this proves
once again once again for those who you
know some who leave Islam because oh no
this is a man's religion etc once again
it's time has been proven right once
again and it's time is there as a
solution and you have left your religion
because of something that just give this
bitter truth it's a bitter truth and
it's there and some of these sister
females who have left their in
relationships where their boyfriend is
got mistress and girlfriend is cheating
so you've left this time for something
that your boyfriend's doing anyway so
that's your loss so promises hope you
guys enjoyed this if you would like me
to carry on doing more social
experiments with the SurveyMonkey want
me to ask specific questions comment in
the section below I would use that go
out there and do the same survey hope
this has been beneficial for you guys
and answered your doubts and to an
example sisters assalamualaikum what I
meant